THE PROCESS.
OKAY, WE HAVE A LOT MORE TO GET
TO, BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT, BUT
JOINING US, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, FORMER INTERIM DNC
CHAIRWOMAN DONNA BRAZILE.
I'M GOING TO HAVE A LIGHTNING
ROUND WITH --
>> SEAN, FIRST OF ALL, YOU
SHOULD SAY, WELCOME, DONNA.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> Sean: WELCOME, I HAVE KNOWN
YOU FOR YEARS, WE HAVE HAD A
VERY FRIENDLY, I WOULD SAY
CORDIAL RELATIONSHIP, WE HAVE
MET AT A LOT OF DEBATES AND A
LOT OF CONVENTIONS.
WE ALWAYS HAVE A GOOD TIME.
WE ASK HOW EACH OTHER ARE DOING,
AND WE NEVER AGREE ON MUCH, DO
WE?
>> NO, BUT THAT IS NOT THE
POINT.
THE POINT IS THAT IT IS A GREAT
HONOR TO BE BACK ON YOUR SHOW.
HE AND I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO
THESE CONVERSATIONS.
I AM NOT RUNNING -- FIRST OF ALL
I WILL NOT USE MY MICROPHONE TO
RUN FOR ANYTHING.
I'M MAKING NO ANNOUNCEMENTS
TONIGHT, BUT I'M GLAD TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT ON ST. JOSEPH'S DAY.
>> Sean: JUST FOR BEING ON THE
SHOW, YOU WILL GET IN TROUBLE
WITH SOME DEMOCRATS.
WHY ARE YOU ON "HANNITY"'S SHOW?
HE IS NOT A NICE GUY, AND THEN
YOU WILL HAVE TO TELL HIM THAT
HE IS NOT THAT BAD.
>> YOU KNOW, A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO YOU HAD ME ON THE SHOW, AND
WE TALKED ABOUT MY NEW BOOK WITH
FOUR -- THREE OTHER WOMEN, SO
YOU HAVE HAD ME ON THE SHOW
BEFORE.
SO THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
AGAIN.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL, FOR THOSE THAT
SAY THAT WE DO NOT HAVE VARYING
OPINIONS, I COULD GO DOWN THE
LIST, AND IF I DO, I WILL
PROBABLY GET IN TROUBLE, SO I
WILL STAY AT PLAY FROM TROUBLE
FOR ONCE IN MY LIFE.
WE WILL PLAY A LIGHTNING ROUND.
I'M JUST ASKING YOU TO PLAY
ALONG.
MEDICARE FOR ALL IS GOING TO BE
$3.3 TRILLION FOR EVERY YEAR FOR
TEN YEARS.
AND PEOPLE LIKE KAMALA HARRIS
SAY THAT PEOPLE WOULD HAVE NO
CHOICE AT PRIVATE HEALTH CARE,
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> WE ARE IN THE BEGINNING OF A
VERY EXTENSIVE CONVERSATION.
IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT RADICALISM,
IT IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
AMERICANS --
>> Sean: THIS IS A LIGHTNING
ROUND, I'M ASKING
DONNA BRAZILE --
>> COME ON.
I CANNOT DO 2 MINUTES?
>> Sean: WE ARE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE LIST --
>> KAMALA HARRIS.
>> Sean: AFTER THE LIST THEN I
WILL LET YOU EXPAND.
HOW'S THAT?
>> OVER 56% OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SUPPORT SOME FORM OF
MEDICARE FOR ALL MEDICARE PLUS
ET CETERA.
>> SHOULD PEOPLE BE ALLOWED TO
GET PRIVATE INSURANCE?
>> IF THEY WANT TO KEEP THEIR
PRIVATE INSURANCE AND MAINTAIN
IT AS I WOULD --
>> Sean: YOU DISAGREE WITH
KAMALA HARRIS.
>> NO, I DO NOT DISAGREE.
I HOPE THAT SHE CAN EXPLAIN.
>> Sean: SHE DOUBLE DOWN ON
IT.
>> SHE CAN ENSURE THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO
CANNOT AFFORD THEIR PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS.
WE NEED TO HAVE A GOOD
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS.
>> Sean: WE ARE NOT WORKING
THE LIGHTNING YET, WE HAVE TO
GET THE LIGHTNING.
>> I AM NOT ABOUT LIGHTNING.
COME ON.
>> Sean: WE WILL GIVE YOU TIME
TO EXPAND.
NOW A LOT OF YOUR PARTY, EIGHT
STATES AND EVEN CONGRESS WANT TO
LATE TERM ABORTIONS, IN ONE CASE
YOU HAD A WOMAN IN
VIRGINIA HOUSE OF DELEGATES SAY
THAT EVEN UP TO THE BIRTHING
PROCESS, DILATION SHE SUPPORTS A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO HAVE AN
ABORTION.
>> THAT WAS NOT EXACTLY TRUE,
BUT LET ME SAY THIS,
DEMOCRATS --
>> Sean: I WILL QUOTE THE
GOVERNOR.
>> DEMOCRATS BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS A CHOICE THAT WOMEN SHOULD
HAVE A SAY IN.
WE BELIEVE THAT --
>> Sean: IN THE NINTH MONTH OF
PREGNANCY?
>> LOOK AT, WE BELIEVE --
>> Sean: YES?
THE NINTH MONTH OF PREGNANCY
WHEN THE CHILD IS VIABLE?
>> I AM NOT A DOCTOR AND I WILL
NOT TELL ANYONE WANT TO DO WITH
HIS OR HER BODY.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY ALSO
BELIEVES VERY STRONGLY THAT
ABORTIONS --
>> Sean: SO A BOARD IN 48
HOURS AND SHE DECIDES TO HAVE AN
ABORTION, WE DO NOT HAVE A
DUTY AND RESPONSIBILITY --
>> YOU ARE ASKING DONNA BRAZILE,
SEAN.
>> Sean: DONNA BRAZILE, I AM
ASKING YOU.
>> I BELIEVE AS A WOMAN I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE A FULL RANGE OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES.
>> Sean: THAT IS THE ANSWER.
>> I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
DECISION THAT I SHOULD HAVE AND
IN CONSULTATION WITH MY DOCTOR
AND OTHER MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS.
THAT IS THE POSITION I HAVE
TAKEN.
>> Sean: DO YOU SUPPORT TO THE
NEW GREEN DEALS GOAL OF GETTING
RID OF ALL OIL AND GAS IN
TEN YEARS?
>> I BELIEVE THAT HR ONE OH NINE
SHOULD BE DEBATED AND I BELIEVET
SHOULD BE DEBATED AND I BELIEVEA
IT
IS GOING TO GO BEFORE AT LEAST
405 COMMITTEE'S AND WE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE.
--
>> Sean: SHOULD WE GET RID OF
BOILING GAS?
>> WE NEED CLEANER SOURCES,
CLEANER RESOURCES.
AND YES, TEN YEARS FROM NOW, --
>> Sean: DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
WE SHOULD REPLACE --
>> I CANNOT DO THIS IN 30
SECONDS, THESE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
>> Sean: WHAT PART OF THE
GREEN NEW DEAL?
IT SAYS IN THE GREEN NEW DEAL,
HANG ON, IT SAYS THAT EVERYTHING
IS GOING TO BE FREE AND THAT --
>> NO, THAT IS NOT TRUE.
>> Sean: AND WE WILL GET RID
OF OIL AND GAS AND ALL
COMBUSTION ENGINES AND
EVENTUALLY COWS.
DONNA, DONNA, DONNA, HELP ME
OUT.
IT SAYS IN TEN YEARS, IN TEN
YEARS THEY ARE GOING TO GET RID
OF OIL, GAS, THE COMBUSTION
ENGINE, AND HOPEFULLY SOON
THEREAFTER AIRPLANES AND COWS.
IT IS BLACK AND WHITE.
AND I'M ASKING DO YOU SUPPORT
THAT --
>> THAT IS NOT.
THEY HAVE GONE AFTER MANY PEOPLE
AND SAID THESE THINGS ABOUT THE
GREAT --
>> Sean: POLITIFACT'S.
>> I AM BELIEVING THAT THEY ARE
A CREDIBLE SOURCE.
AND THIS IS A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
HR 109.
LOOK AT IT YOURSELF AND STOP
TRYING TO EXPLOIT THE FACT THAT
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT -- YOU
MADE ME READ THE DARN THING
AFTER I WAS ON THE SHOW LAST
TIME.
AND I'M LIKE, THERE IS NOTHING
IN THIS THAT SAID ABOUT THE
AIRPLANES.
>> Sean: I HAVE A COPY OF HER
RIGHT HERE.
IT IS IN HERE WORD FOR WORD.
LET ME ASK YOU THE NEXT QUESTIO
QUESTION.
DO YOU THINK THAT IT IS A GOOD
IDEA TO SIKORA THE SOUTHERN
BORDERS WITH WALLS?
>> I BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO USE
MULTIPLE EFFORTS IN NORTH AND
SOUTH.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THE
PRESIDENT PLANNED WHAT WILL
WORK.
>> Sean: DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO HAVE
I.C.E. AND OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS?
>> I BELIEVE THAT WE NEED
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
>> Sean: DO YOU SUPPORT
KEEPING I.C.E.?
>> I BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO
REFORM I.C.E.
I DO NOT LIKE THE JOB THAT THEY
ARE DOING NOW.
I'VE NOT TAKING A PERSONAL
POSITION ON THAT, BUT I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
AND I DO NOT SPEAK FOR ALL
DEMOCRATS.
I ONLY SPEAK FOR DONNA.
>> Sean: YOU ARE THE FORMER
HEAD OF THE DNC, DO YOU WANT THE
VOTING AGE LOWERED TO 16?
DO YOU WANT THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE REMOVED?
AND DO YOU WANT MORE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES ADDED TO
THE NINTH?
>> WHAT I LIKE TO SEE THE VOTING
AGE LOWERED AS SEVERAL COUNTRIES
INCLUDING I BELIEVE BRAZIL, A
COUNTRY NAMED AFTER MY FAMILY,
AND BRUSSELS, OTHERS, IN HEIGHTS
FIELD, MARYLAND, AS WELL AS
TAKOMA PARK, THEY ARE
EXPERIMENTING WITH THIS.
WE NEED TO EXPERIMENT WITH MORE
WAYS TO GET THEM INVOLVED IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
>> Sean: DO YOU THINK --
>> AND THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE,
THERE HAVE BEEN FOUR TIME SINCE
1860 WHERE THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE, AS YOU WELL KNOW, ONE
OF THE POPULAR VOTERS, ONE OF
THE POPULAR VOTES HAS LOST THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
I'M ACTUALLY READING A GREAT
BOOK ABOUT THIS, SEAN.
WE WILL HAVE ANOTHER
CONVERSATION TO TALK ABOUT IT.
>> Sean: IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT YOU HEAR OF THE CURRENT
PROMPT OF 2020 CANDIDATES WHERE
YOU SAY WOW, THEY ARE GOING TO
PROMISE A GUARANTEED SALARY
AND PROMISE FAMILY LEAVE,
MEDICAL LEAVE, PRE-K EDUCATION,
COLLEGE EDUCATION, GUARANTEED,
GUARANTEED HEALTHY FOOD,
GUARANTEED RETIREMENT,
GUARANTEED HEALTH CARE?
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT ADDS
UP -- THE NEW DEAL, THE GREEN
NEW DEAL ADDS UP TO $94 TRILLION
IN TEN YEARS.
TO DO YOU THINK THAT IS
SOCIALISM?
>> FIRST OF ALL I THINK THAT IS
FUZZY MATH, AND NO, THE TEXTBOOK
DEFINITION OF SOCIALISM, NO.
>> Sean: THAT IS THE CEO.
>> THESE ARE POLICY IDEAS THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE OFFERING.
MANY DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES ARE
OFFERING TO THE VOTERS.
THE VOTERS WILL ULTIMATELY
DECIDE WHAT ARE THESE POLICY
PRESCRIPTIONS THEY BELIEVE IN
AND WHAT CANDIDATES THEY BELIEVE
CAN CARRY THEIR AGENDA.
THIS IS WHY WE HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AND DEBATE.
AND SEAN, IF YOU ARE NOT
INTERESTED IN LISTENING TO THE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES, THEN LOOK
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
BUT THESE ARE IMPORTANT IDEAS.
>> Sean: I AM LOOKING
ELSEWHERE, TRUST ME.
>> THESE ARE MY IDEAS, AND I
ALSO WANT TO TELL YOU WHY YOU
DISAGREE WITH YOU, I'VE KNOWN
ADAM SCHIFF FOR A LONG TIME.
YOU MENTION ADAM SCHIFF, HE IS A
VERY DECENT AND HONORABLE
PERSON.
>> Sean: KNOW HE IS NOT.
>> I WILL TELL THEM TO COME ON
YOUR SHOW.
>> Sean: TELL THEM TO COME ON,
I AM OFFERING HIM FOR HOURS, I
HAVE EVERYTHING DOCUMENTED.
I WILL HAVE THE INTERVIEW.
>> LOOK, I'M NOT YOUR BROKER AND
I DON'T KNOW WHO WILL RETURN
YOUR CALL IN THE OFFICE.
AT --
>> Sean: I WILL GIVE YOU A
MINUTE TO ANSWER THE LAST
QUESTION, LET ME GET TO THE LAST
QUESTION, THE LAST QUESTION IS
THIS.
BARACK OBAMA WAS PRESIDENT FOR
EIGHT YEARS, PUTTING ASIDE THE
$150 BILLION IDIOTIC OR RAINY IN
DEAL, THIS IS WHAT THE ECONOMY
WAS AFTER 13 MORE YEARS,
30 MILLION MORE AMERICANS ON
FOOD STAMPS, 80 MILLION MORE IN
POVERTY, LOWEST PARTICIPATION
RATES AND SEE '70s, THE WORKS
WERE COVERED YOU SINCE THE
LOWEST INCOME RATE IN 40 YEARS,
THE PRESIDENT THAT DID NOT REACH
50% GDP IN ANY YEARS AS
PRESIDENT AND ACCUMULATED MORE
DEATH AND 43 PRESIDENTS
COMBINED.
>> HE HAS NOT MET THE THIRD ONE.
>> Sean: BUT DONALD TRUMP
BECOMES PRESIDENT GETS RID OF
REGULATIONS.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU TIME TO
ANSWER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GETS IN OFFICE,
WE ARE NOW ENERGY INDEPENDENT
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN SEVEN
YEARS, WE ARE NET EXPORTER OF
ENERGY.
WE NOW HAVE CREATED 6 MILLION
NEW JOBS, OVER 1 MILLION FEWER
PEOPLE ON FOOD STAMPS AND IN
POVERTY.
THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
EVER FOR AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE AND YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT, TELL ME WHY COULD
NOT OBAMA GET DONE IN EIGHT
YEARS WHAT TRUMP GOT DONE IN
TWO?
>> FIRST OF ALL HE COULD NOT
HAVE GOTTEN ANYTHING DONE HAD
OBAMA NOT BEGAN TO PUT IN THE
HARD WORK AND THE MUSCLE AND THE
QUALITY ENERGY TO GET THE
ECONOMY BACK ON ITS FEET AFTER
THE GREAT RECESSION OF 2008.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THE LEGACY OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA WILL BE ONE OF
HELP INFUSING, SUSTAINING THE
ECONOMY, HELPING TO BUILD THE
ENGINE OF THE COUNTRY AND
GETTING MORE PEOPLE --
>> Sean: WHY DID IT TAKE EIGHT
YEARS AND WE HAVE 13 MILLION
MORE AMERICANS ON FOOD STAMPS?
A MILLION MORE IN POVERTY?
HE SET ONE RECORD AFTER ANOTHER.
>> YOU FORGET WHAT STACY ABRAM
SAID, I DON'T WANT THIS
PRESIDENT TO FAIL, JUST WANT HIM
TO TELL THE TRUTH.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU WHAT THE
LAST PRESIDENT DID --
>> Sean: I JUST WANT HIM TO
TWEET LAST.
>> I SAW THE PRESIDENT ROLL UP
HIS SLEEVE AND GET TO WORK.
PRESIDENT OBAMA DID THAT --
>> Sean: THIS IS WHAT HE DID.
AND IN ISRAEL.
>> THAT'S WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
SHOULD DO.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT THE
ROCKETS BEING FIRED OVER JAPAN?
>> MAKING SURE THAT EVERY
AMERICAN GETS A HEAD START AND A
HEALTHY START.
THAT'S WHAT WE ALL WANT.
>> Sean: I WILL TAKE TRUMP'S
RECORD OVER OBAMA'S FAILED
RECORD EVERY DAY PARADE WELCOME
TO THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL --
>> I WILL TAKE OBAMA'S GOOD
RECORD AND I HOPE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL CONTINUE TO
FOLLOW --
>> Sean: ONE DAY YOU SHOULD
FILL IN ON MY SHOW AND HOST THE
SHOW.
>> , SEAN, CAN YOU IMAGINE IF I
COULD BE SEAN HANNITY FOR LIKE
30 MINUTES A NIGHT, COME ON,
BABY.
>> Sean: YOU CAN HANDLE IT.
YOU'LL BE GOOD.
>> BY THE WAY, THANK YOU.
IT IS A GREAT HONOR.
I KNOW WE DO NOT ALWAYS AGREE,